[Musique]
il part aux Amériques c'est une histoire
qui ressemble beaucoup à un compte deit
manita Plata parlez-moi un peu de ce
départ pour les Amériques et voilà un
jour je me su
trouv le photographe n'est-ce pas
m'endu jouer il m' proposé d' à
l'Amérique comme j'ai peur de monter
dans le bateau et l'avion je voulais pas
all aller rien faire vous avez attendu
combien de temps 2 ans et maintenant
cette fois vous êtes décidé ah oui
pouress venu des Colombia m' fait un
contrat pournigol la plus grande salle
de concert d'Amérique oui vous savez que
les Américains vous appellent le plus
grand guitariste flamenco du monde oui
mademoiselle ça vous fait un peu peur
non très peur même jou tout seul au
canall ouais dites-moi votre guitare
elle est très belle elle a beaucoup de
valeur elle comporte des signatures oui
le baron Madeleine Rena le peintre
sartou François Perrier et Picasso
Picasso grand amateur de taureau et de
guitare et de Flavin comme chacun sait
[Musique]
oui
ơi
ha
[Musique]
a
coraz
Mo
[Musique]
VI
sbij